le va-et-vient est constant à l'Hôpital
de Montréal pour enfants
des familles viennent ici en dernier
recours le taux d'occupation à l'urgence
frôle 200%, une situation jugée
difficile depuis plusieurs semaines il
n'y a pas de médecins
longtemps jour après jour il y a des
témoignages de citoyens qui se disent
tout simplement incapable d'avoir accès
à des soins de santé pressez d'expliquer
ce qu'il compte faire le ministre de la
Santé rappelle que des mesures ont déjà
été mises en place le 81 1 fonctionne
très bien mais on manque de personnel
pour répondre au téléphone il y a
tellement d'appels
[Musique]
la ligne pédiatrique 8 1 a été mise à
disposition des parents d'enfants
malades le mois dernier pour désengorger
les urgences mais les délais pour parler
à une infirmière
s'allongement jusqu'à une heure et demie
peut-être même les deux heures il y a
d'autres périodes où est-ce que c'est
moins achalandé puis donc que c'est
moins long on pourrait prendre jusqu'à
5000 infirmières pour répondre au
téléphone recruter assez d'infirmières à
la retraite et d'étudiants est un
objectif ambitieux
professionnels en soin dans le réseau de
la santé si on ne les a pas actuellement
pour le réseau public on ne les a
définitivement pas non plus pour le
secteur du 81 ça fait quand même 15 ans
15 ans que je pratique puis honnêtement
j'ai jamais vu ça un automne aussi à
chalandais le ministre de la Santé
prévient que la situation dans les
hôpitaux du Québec restera difficile
dans les prochaines semaines il presse
les Québécois de se faire vacciner
contre la covid et l'influenza et
demande aux parents de garder les à la
maison s'ils ont des symptômes déjà près
de 120 000 enfants sont absents du
réseau de l'éducation à l'heure actuelle
ici Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada
Montréal